c'est désormais officiel joe biden et le
candidat démocrate à la présidentielle
américaine une investiture à l'issue
d'une conversation virtuelle et d'un
vote électronique covic 19 oblige saluée
par plusieurs personnalités dans un
moment comme celui que nous vivons le
bureau ovale devrait être un centre de
commandement au lieu de cela c'est
l'oeil du cyclone
il n'y règne que le chaos notre parti
est uni pour vous offrir un choix très
différents
un président qui va travailler un homme
de bon sens qui fait son boulot
félicitations de jo je suis fier de toi
sans surprise michelle obama s'est elle
aussi rallié aux antilles trimpe y
allant de son petit tacle sur l'actuel
président à chaque fois que nous nous
tournons vers la maison blanche pour une
direction ou du réconfort ou un semblant
de stabilité
ce que nous recevons à la place c'est du
chaos de la division et un manque
complet et totale d'empathie
fidèle à lui-même donald trump n'a pas
manqué de répondre à l'ancienne première
dame
quelqu'un peut-il s'il vous plaît
expliqué à michelle obama que donald
trump ne serais pas ici dans la belle
maison blanche
sans le travail accompli par son mari
barack obama by john n'est que le
résultat d'une réflexion après coup ce
qui explique cette progression très
tardive et sans enthousiasme une plus
d'encouragement et de soutien dans un
camp démocrate qui contrairement aux
apparences est loin d'être soudés
autrefois approche de bernie sanders
la plupart des démocrates semblent
contraint de soutenir un programme et un
candidat loin de leurs convictions
politiques
souvenez-vous aux dernières primaires
démocrates deux courants se sont
clairement opposés celui de la gauche
socialiste incarné par bernie sanders et
celui des centristes porté par joe biden
l'ex vice-président vainqueur des
primaires n'a aujourd'hui d'autre choix
que de jouer la carte du consensus et de
multiplier les consultations pour
assembler au sein de son propre camp
ce qui unit les démocrates c'est la
farouche envie de renverser donald trump
et de l'empêcher de faire un second
mandat mais en off le soutien envers ben
hayden peut s'avérer bien moins fervents
ne sous-estimé pas la capacité de joe a
tout foiré devancé dans les sondages
donald trump eux semblent déterminés à
renverser la tendance
quitte à multiplier les déplacements en
pleine crise du coronavirus en deux
jours il a sillonné quatre états dont le
wisconsin où devait se tenir la
convention d'investiture de joe biden et
le minnesota où avaient éclaté les
premières manifestations en hommage à
georges floyd à chaque apparition
publique le locataire de la maison
blanche n'a pas manqué de tacler son
adversaire joe biden est une marionnette
de l'extrême gauche qui essayent
d'effacer nos frontières d'éliminer la
police d'endoctriner nos enfants de
calomnier nos héros et s'il ce pilonnage
semble porter ses fruits
cette semaine
annan a publié un sondage ne donnant
plus que quatre points d'avancé à joe
biden au niveau national une véritable
percée pour l'ancien magna de
l'immobilier qui accusait un retard de
14 points lors du dernier sondage
effectué en juin une remontée que
certains observateurs regardent avec
prudence en effet selon le même sondage
12 % des électeurs de donald trump ont
déclaré être prêts à changer de candidat
54% des électeurs américains déclarent
eux toujours désapprouvé sa façon de
gérer les affaires de l'état
en cause notamment est la crise du
coronavirus malgré une fin de mandat
tout remonter un retard dans les
sondages donald trump est loin de
s'avouer vaincu et ses soutiens
demeurent nombreux et l'homme a déjà
prouvé par le passé quand campagne il
était capable de renverser des montagnes
celui qui avait déjà fait mentir les
sondages lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle américaine
arrivera-t-il à renouveler cette
prouesse réponse en novembre prochain